M pass master pass pass pass down
rejected godam it you can't make this up
SC 1 through 10 what would you rate me
like an e for real yeah I got a kiss on
the
[Music]
teat the audacity this is why I called
my network the audacity Network cuz the
amount of things I see where it's like
the audacity how much do you think you
guys should spend on an engagement brand
well I think the rule is like threee
salary so threee
salary what up guys welcome to the J
curly things YouTube channel and welcome
to my reaction series before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in and
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt in the comments okay so today I
am watching Mike San give a woman a
reality check I have been on his podcast
before very intelligent guy let's let's
check this out range 3545 3545 good
we're excluding married men we don't
care what race or is there a particular
race we don't care what race we're going
to pick any race what is the minimum
height remember your friends don't lie
this is the one where everybody all the
girls start grimacing be real what is
the minimum height for the guy minimum
510 minimum 510 there we go now here's
another one I have to tell you this CU
yeah they they say that being a tall
woman is like the CSE of death on you
like that that makes you the least
likely to marry or something it seem
obvious but it's not we're excl I was
like dang it I'll shrink you know what I
mean obese men correct or would we allow
heavy fat fat men no no fat men okay
like let's be honest guy who wants to
dat a fat but he's got to be 510 right
and he's between the age of 35 and 45
and he's not obese right ready here's
another one men minimum
income see look at the look at her face
it's so great that's a difficult
question yeah 100 key 100 and the reason
women think like this a lot of them have
these cushy jobs and make more money
than they really deserve they have no
idea how much harder it is for men to
make money a lot of these chicks are't
only fans a lot of these chicks are
being taken out to nice restaurants by
men that make way more than they do so
they have this diluted sense of money
yeah so we're talking about a man who is
35 to 45 he's not married we're
excluding anyone under 510 excluding
obese men and we're excluding men that
make under $100,000 a year so my
question for you is what percentage of
men in the United States do you think
that is 40% 40% of men yeah less than 1%
of
[Laughter]
men it's less than 40 how would you
think it's 40% yeah so so let's let's go
through the problems you had here why
what's the problem with older than
imagine so so when you said not married
and not obese you excluded almost all
men like 40 something what percentage
75% of Americans are obese you know
you're talking to me I live in Hollywood
everyone handsome it's so hard to yeah
right so but you thought 40% of men now
ready let's keep going ready okay so
when you say not you're actually
excluding a ton of men and guess what
the good-looking men who are fit and
make a lot of money guess what they all
are they're married and you excluded you
see the problem there I don't know but I
thought I I thought it was too nice to
say 510 to be honest I'm like like
better 6 zero but 5 I mean obviously
most of the good I'm making six figures
oh my gosh get taken and get married
younger so I don't know why all these
women that are like 35 years old boss
chicks think they're going to get 1% man
cuz you won't they'll all be gone and no
matter how much we show these women how
delusional they are they go back to
being delusional 30 seconds later a lot
of them are actually okay living in
delusion cuz they think they're the
special one or the one that women always
think they're special always exception
to the rule that's going to get that 1%
man then they hit the wall lose they
looks and realize they've got to get
cats if the cats will have them so today
I'm here with Aaron what age range do
you want your Idle Man to be I'm 22 so
I'm looking for a man that's like 30 to
35 what race do you want your idol man
to be oh black black
okay what's the minimal height you want
your Ido man to be like 5 five I'm 5T so
I don't care yeah what's the minimal
income you want your ideal man to make
100K the chances of your idal man being
out there is
0.75 we going to help her we going to I
work in a strip cloth so I'm not taking
nothing less than six figures okay are
you delusional do do you suffer from a
mental illness how much money does a guy
need to make in order to be with you a
million dollar a month he needs to be
making to be dating me not
go me look at her
ion
dollar she's got to be trolling this
can't be real I don't even think I've
gotten a number that high he needs to be
making to be dating me what men are you
around going to happen no not going to
happen how tall does he need to be like
6'5 minimum I'm not tall enough hell no
I'm sorry funny thing
is short Kings but like not for me not
for me
you date a guy the funny thing is if a
girl did that to or a guy did that to a
girl and did the same thing with like
being fat or something the women would
feel some type of way about it the guys
are just like eh make 75k a year yes no
that's not enough
no I it's like a lot of nerve make less
than me so no yeah
like see like the woman in the first
clip they probably want a top 1% man and
if they want a top 1% man he's going to
have options and if he's got options
he's not going to pick any near
[Music]
[Laughter]
you pass smash
pass
rejected I mean some of these women have
quite the nerve you know what I mean I I
mean I don't have to say it do I I mean
I I know there's something you can't do
get on the treadmill you know what
I God damn it you can't make this [__]
[Music]
up we must stay focused Brothers we must
stay focused I want your girl stay the
fu away her bro I don't even like skinny
girls exactly why the [__] talking to
her for cuz she does my homework I
didn't want to tell you this but someone
said she she belongs to the
class would you date someone who's plus-
siiz no I'd like to work out a lot so I
like someone who like has the same
interest interests as me do you go to
the gym often yeah I try to so when
you're at the gym do you ever see a big
girl or a big guy yeah so pluses people
do go to the gym not enough otherwise
they'd be
thin I mean they go to the gym to get in
shape and if they're not in shape
they're not going to keep up of him when
he's at the gym are they so if they get
in shape maybe you'll be interested and
just cuz an overweight person has
healthy habits like going to the gym and
not smoking doesn't mean they're healthy
go I like this double reaction disease
or diabetes what do you guys think about
lizo do you think she's like healthy
yeah she's vegan like she's why do women
lie to each other guys I spent I spent
yesterday arguing with a chick over if
fat chicks are fat I'm seeing her on TI
Tok she's dancing she's working out do
you think lizo is healthy no why don't
you think because she's
[Laughter]
overweight no
way fair enough to them for laughing
about it and now they've heard someone
else talking about it they might realize
how ridiculous it all is how much does a
wedding ring have to cost baby it could
be okay why are women with chess tatos
having high stand I'm sorry wealthy men
don't typically pick women with chess
tattoos typically $50 it really doesn't
matter I just want to be in love I want
to be oh she was a good answer wow and I
want a happy he I thought this was going
to different way I'm sorry chica I
misjudged you marriage so the ring I
mean what the cost of the Ring it really
doesn't mean anything cuz it's not like
I'm going go sell it but the ring is
just a symbol of my commitment to my man
so however much he can really afford
whatever he feels like I totally thought
this was going a different direction
give me listen These Hoes have three
kids with no marriage so I rather the
ring and my man than the cost of it that
don't matter to me oh wow look at that
so like he could give you a ring pop and
you would baby take me to the courthouse
with that ring pop thank you hello this
is how it should be a woman should want
to marry you because she wants to
solidify the relationship not because
she wants all this materialistic
[__] that comes with it a lot of
marriages these days are not serious and
they're all for show and that's why
they're not lasting how much do you
think a guy should spend on an
engagement
ring um these women are going to be
delusional I think 20K uh yeah okay
there it is there it is how much do you
think you guys should spend on
engagement well I think the rule is like
threee salary so at least that threee
salary what do you think you look like
CH
women it's so superficial that is so
superficial we are very
different that's all I need to know
thank you don't have time no
sh let me talk you have good night no
but we can't be friends don't want to be
my friend this man met this woman online
I think she's from Colombia so he flew
out to Colombia she probably thought he
was rich realized he wasn't and tried to
friend zone him so he said [__] this I'm
gone I'm done and this is why you got to
be careful fellas being a passport bro
meeting these women online especially
from these countries that don't have a
lot of money cuz a lot of them don't
want you they want your money or they
want
[Music]
paperwork check the mic and make sure it
sound right
boy
that hurt you know when you act
uninterested and he actually leaves you
alone then you throw a plastic cup in
him ladies take noes this is exactly
what not to do when you approach a man
what is the most toxic thing you've done
in a relationship oh we could easily
answer yeah I can answer that ran him
over with my car I beg your pardon you
actually ran him
over no we really like we really argued
and I'd basically gone on his laptop and
found every girl in London I got in my
car he like stood in front my car like
don't go so I just drove into why are
they
laughing enough sounds like he deserved
it really weird
you
together that he never made me his
girlfriend [__] deserve it I should
hit him harder I said I think women are
more violent than men I really do when
they have the opportunity we love we
love to be violent oh oh you crazy I
don't think I'm considered a ho no more
I don't really got no nobody in the last
like sorry that's not how it works chica
for 3 years she said no more say no no
your your Hess can get deleted your Hess
can get deleted I killed 10 people but
it was 10 years ago so now I'm not a
murderer yeah I don't I I I don't think
that's how it works like if a guy is
nice that means he gets no girls and
that's like a turn off you know what I
mean get some help put me in he put me
into nursing school he got got my hair
nails everything done so he up here on
this level I'm down here on this level
you get where I'm going he got me up
here with him cuz he was making good
money but then he ended up losing his
job two years ago lost his job and now
he broke what did I do leave
L broke up with him and got on because
I'm not going to take care of no grown
man I'm not doing that
wow wow ladies it's time to get a job
get a job evil world we live in there's
a lot of women out there that will be by
your side when you got everything but
there's very few that will stay there
when you got nothing it's the worst date
you've ever been on just like going to a
restaurant they don't pay this one time
this guy we went mini golfing and he
made me pay a guy took me downtown and I
basically paid for it's going to be more
common it's going to be more common
you're going to see more 50/50 you're
going to see more women paying you have
another day after or something no
definitely not did you ever see him
again we work together not supposed to
where you eat I actually don't even
think it's the end of the world like who
cares I know that I don't think you do
now me personally if I invite a woman
out on the then I'm going to offer to
pay unless she acts like a complete knob
in which case I'm going to go and she
can pay for herself but the funny thing
is a lot of these women claim to be
feminists which means they want equal
rights 50/50 for everything so F yeah a
lot of them do they say it's it's
feminist when I feel like it pissed off
or turned off every time a man ask to go
50/50 then I don't really get it are
yall dating no yeah yeah I don't like
them together as a couple I don't like
the look I don't I don't think they like
look good together he said yeah you said
no I'm not going to lie you look very
beautiful though thank you said scale 1
through 10 what would you rate me like
an e for real yeah I got a kiss on the
teat the audacity this is why I called
my network the audacity Network cuz the
amount of things I see where it's like
the
audacity look at bro don't feel sorry
for yourself and hang around she was
never yours and it was probably never
your turn either where she belongs she
belongs to the streets yeah I some
sometimes guys these Street interviews
are kind of depressing and it's funny
because do you know what they'll say
they'll say oh you guys bring specific
girls on the show then I'll show you
Street interviews I'll be like here I've
done it on the street too same thing and
then they'll say oh but you're like
selectively listening I'm like what then
I'll look at other people's Street
interviews they're like well that's just
what goes viral or maybe this shows a
change in the culture I don't make up
the rules I it's not my fault the
culture is this way I was just born in
this time period guys all right let's
like the video on your way out and
subscribe to the channnel make sure you
ring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time